[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serin in allen einen schönen
guten Abend katja hat später wieder die
sportlichen Nachrichten des Tages
schönen guten Abend wir blicken jetzt
gemeinsam auf die Themen an diesem
Mittwoch
der katholischen Kirche laufen die
Mitglieder davon mehr als eine halbe
Million Gläubige sind im vergangenen
Jahr ausgetreten
Politikverdrossenheit und rechtsextreme
Ansichten Studie aus Leipzig sieht im
Osten Unzufriedenheit mit der Demokratie
im Alltag
und im Visier der fahrende Razzien beim
Immobilienkonzern Adler Group wegen des
Verdachts der falschbilanzierung und
Untreue
[Musik]
nie zuvor traten innerhalb eines Jahres
mehr Menschen aus der katholischen
Kirche aus es ist ein anhaltender Trend
der wenn er sich weiter so dramatisch
beschleunigt neben der Kirche wohl auch
große Teile der deutschen Sozial- und
Bildungslandschaft treffen könnte
schauen wir jetzt mal gemeinsam auf
diesen negativ Rekord vergangenes Jahr
sind mehr als eine halbe Million
ausgetreten die Zahl liegt damit
deutlich über dem bisherigen Rekordjahr
2021 da hatten mehr als 350.000
Katholikinnen und Katholiken der Kirche
den Rücken gekehrt im Erzbistum München
und Freising sind nach einem Gutachten
zum Missbrauch dort die Austritt Zahlen
in die Höhe geschossen die meisten
Austritte die gab es letztes Jahr im
Erzbistum Köln mehr jetzt von Stefan
leifert
über 50.000 Kirchenaustritte allein im
Erzbistum Köln das gab's noch nie
gestern erst eine Razzia bei Erzbischof
Wölki im Zuge des Missbrauchs Skandals
heute die Nachricht die Gläubigen gehen
in Scharen auch deutschlandweit zeugt
die Statistik regelrecht von einer
Flucht aus der Kirche
das ist heute ein bitterer Tag an dem
auch nichts schön geredet werden muss
diese gigantischen Austrittszahlen die
uns Schmerzen als Kirchen Deutschland
zeigen dass wir tiefen
glaubwürdigkeiten Vertrauenskrise sind
wir müssen jetzt alle Anstrengungen
ansetzen um aus dieser Krise irgendwie
herauszukommen die Kirche ist dabei
ihren Charakter als Volkskirche zu
verlieren ein dramatischer
Vertrauensverlust und eine Erosion die
nicht mehr aufzuhalten zu sein scheint
die Zahlen sprechen
sehr und sie handelt nicht entschieden
genug Christian in der Kirche mit
Zukunftsvision anzugehen die verstörende
Missbrauchsgeschichte jahrzehntelange
Vertuschung und der mangelnde
Reformwille viele Amtsträger zählen zu
den vielen Gründen für den
austrittsrekord
gibt es mehrere Gründe einmal natürlich
die ganzen missbrauchsvorfälle okay ich
habe ein problem Zeichen zu setzen
dementsprechend reagieren auch auch
viele Christen die schon seit
Jahrzehnten in der Kirche sind
vielleicht doch und sagen es ist nicht
mehr meins ne der Synodale Weg weckte
Hoffnungen die enttäuscht wurden der
Glaube an Reformen schwindet ich kann
nur appellieren an die Menschen die in
der Kirche engagiert sind weiter
engagiert zu bleiben sich für Reformen
für die dringend notwendigen Reformen
einzusetzen es ist eine Kernschmelze die
Deutschlands Kirche gerade erlebt die
Statistik von heute gießt das in
dramatische zahlen
bei uns im Studio jetzt Jürgen Erbacher
erst der Leiter der ZDF-Redaktion Kirche
und leben hallo Herr Erbacher also es
ist der vorläufige Höhepunkt dieser
Austrittswelle wie ließe sich diese
Entwicklung ja vermeiden bzw wie kann
man den begegnen die Prognosen gehen
davon aus dass die Zahlen auch weiter
hoch bleiben werden aber entscheidend
wir haben es gerade gehört sind die
Reformen die müssen jetzt konsequent
umgesetzt werden eine große Mehrheit der
deutschen Bischöfe möchte das auch tun
es gibt eine kleine Minderheit von 45
diözesan Bischöfen die sich da immer
dagegen stellen da müssen sich die
Mehrheit jetzt durchsetzen und muss
vorangehen das ist zum Beispiel beim
Arbeitsrecht gelungen wo weitestgehend
der Lebenswandel keine Rolle mehr spielt
für Arbeitsverhältnisse es gibt auf
nationaler Ebene noch ein paar Themen
bei Transparenz Mitbestimmung die man
sicher lösen kann dann bei den großen
Themen muss Rom mit ins Boot der Vatikan
der Papst zum Beispiel Abschaffung des
pflichtverlebars oder mehr Ämter für
Frauen rum verweigert sich gerade ein
bisschen dem Dialog der Gesprächsfaden
ist weitestgehend abgerissen hier müssen
die Bischöfe wieder schauen dass man
diesen Faden wieder aufgreift weil ohne
Rom wird es nicht gehen aber ohne
Reformen wird das auch nicht weitergehen
was bedeuten diese Austritte
gesamtgesellschaftlich und kulturell der
schwächt die Kirchen die evangelische
Kirche steht ja vor ähnlichen
Herausforderungen das heißt die beiden
Kirchen fallen zunehmend sozusagen als
sozialer Kit auch in der Gesellschaft
aus sie sind zudem eine der größten
Arbeitgeber in Deutschland nach den
staatlichen Stellen wenn die Finanzen
fehlen müssen zunehmend Bildungs- und
Sozialeinrichtungen geschlossen werden
oder man muss versuchen andere Träger zu
finden das ist jüngst bei Schulen zum
Beispiel im Bistum Mainz oder
Eichstädter Fall gewesen das heißt auf
Staat und Gesellschaft kommen hier große
Herausforderungen zu wenn die Kirchen
zunehmend mangels Ressourcen ausfallen
also düstere Perspektiven nicht nur für
die Kirche vielen Dank Erbacher und wie
es um die christlichen Kirchen in
Deutschland bestellt ist bei uns können
Sie das alles noch mal online
nachschauen alle wichtigen Aspekte
nachlesen über die derzeitige
mitgliedersituationen bis zu den
Missbrauchsfällen wie erklären es kurz
und knapp in unserer ZDF heute App
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius ist von
heute an zu Besuch in den USA und bei
seinen Gesprächen wird es hauptsächlich
um Unterstützung für die Ukraine gehen
erst gestern kündigte Washington weitere
Militärhilfe in Höhe von 500 Millionen
Dollar an
Russlands Angriffswellen auf die Ukraine
halten weiter an in kremators im Osten
des Landes starben nach Behördenangaben
mindestens 10 Menschen mehr als 50 sein
verletzt worden Antoine
ein Restaurant mitten im Zentrum von
cramatorsk völlig zerstört getroffen von
russischen Raketen Rettungskräfte suchen
fieberhaft nach Überlebenden das
Restaurant war ein beliebter Treffpunkt
in der Stadt auch bei Soldaten es war
gut besucht als die Raketen einschlugen
unter den Verletzten auch Journalisten
und Schriftsteller unter den Toten auch
Kinder für Präsident selenski ein
weiteres Kriegsverbrechen
dieser Terror beweist uns unter der
ganzen Welt immer wieder das Russland
für all seine Tat nur eines verdient
Niederlage und Tribunal für alle
russischen Mörder und Terroristen
Moskau widerspricht man greife nur
militärische Ziele an so kremme Sprecher
pestkopf
ist die letzte größere Stadt unter
ukrainischer Kontrolle im Osten des
Landes ganz in der Nähe verläuft die
Front wo die Russen mit schwerem
Artillerie vorher versuchen die
ukrainische gegen Offensive zu stoppen
das ukrainische Militär veröffentlichte
heute diese Bilder sie zeigen heftige
Kämpfe bei bachmut
was passiert wenn die Offensive nicht
den gewünschten Erfolg hat den erhofften
Erfolg hat das zu beurteilen müssen wir
uns aufheben dann wenn es soweit ist
falls es soweit kommt ich setze auf die
große Offensive auf die Gegend Offensive
und alles andere wird sich finden die
große Operation der Gegenoffensive
stehen noch bevor hieß es heute aus Kiel
die unsere die Unzufriedenheit mit der
Demokratie ist in ostdeutschen
Bundesländern besonders groß
gleichzeitig gäbe es ein erhebliches
Wählerpotenzial für rechte Parteien zu
diesem Ergebnis kommt eine Studie der
Universität Leipzig
demnach ist nicht mal die Hälfte der
Befragten mit der Demokratie im Alltag
zufrieden fast zwei Drittel halten es
für sinnlos sich politisch zu engagieren
Cornelia schiemens und Nikola Albrecht
berichten
es sind ernüchternde Studienergebnisse
die die Autoren des Leipziger
else-fränkel-brunswick-instituts heute
der Öffentlichkeit präsentieren wir
sehen dass die Ausländerfeindlichkeit
Antisemitismus und
verschwörungsmentalität weit verbreitet
sind befragt wurden rund 3.500 Menschen
in den fünf ostdeutschen Bundesländern
und Ost Berlin die Zustimmung zu
Rechtsextremen Aussagen sei hier hoch so
die Forscher demnach zeigten ein
geschlossenes rechtsextremes Weltbild
rund 11,6% der Befragten in
Sachsen-Anhalt 7,1 Prozent sind es im
Gesamtdurchschnitt zur rechtsextremen
Einstellung gehört auch
Ausländerfeindlichkeit mit
32,7 Prozent ist diese in Sachsen am
höchsten der Durchschnittswert
27,9 Prozent mehr als jede vierte die
Autoren machen eine multiple Krisenlage
dafür verantwortlich Krieg Klimawandel
33 Jahre Transformation seit der Wende
aber auch eine strukturelle
Benachteiligung des bestens den
demokratischen Parteien fehlten Konzepte
die AFD profitiere ich glaube dass die
AFD jetzt nah dran ist ihr Potenzial
auszuschöpfen sie haben die
Rechtsextremen eingestellten Personen
von anderen Parteien eingesammelt sind
noch sehr viele die nicht Fehler sind
die von keiner Partei erreicht werden
der Wunsch nach starker Führung sei im
Osten deutlich ausgeprägt wie eine
weitere studienfrage zeigt was
Deutschland jetzt braucht ist eine
starke Partei die die Volksgemeinschaft
insgesamt verkörpert dieser Aussage
stimmen 26,3% der Befragten voll und
ganz zu weitere 24,9% sind latent also
teilweise dieser Meinung die Studie
dürfte für weiteren Zündstoff sorgen in
der Debatte um hohe AFD Werte und im
Streit über die Benachteiligung
ostdeutscher
im Tarifstreit bei der Bahn hat der
Konzern jetzt eine Schlichtung
vorgeschlagen die Gewerkschaft EVG wurde
um Rückmeldung bis Freitag mittag
gebeten zuvor war bekannt geworden dass
die EVG eigentlich morgen über einen
weiteren Warnstreik entscheiden will
vergangene Woche waren die
Tarifgespräche nach monatelang
Verhandlungen gescheitert
studieren einen pardon eine andere
Meldung ein tödlicher Polizeischutz bei
einer Verkehrskontrolle hat in
Frankreich schwere Krawalle ausgelöst
Präsident macron rief zur Ruhe auf und
nannte den Tod des Jugendlichen
unverzeihlich der 17-Jährige war gestern
morgen bei Paris aus nächster Nähe
erschossen worden als er während der
Polizei Kontrolle plötzlich los vor der
Schütze wurde festgenommen in der Nacht
setzt seine aufgebrachte Menschenmenge
Häuser und Autos in Brand auch heute
werden Ausschreitungen in Pariser
Vororten befürchtet
der Immobilienkonzern Adler Group
besitzt rund 27.000 Mietwohnungen und
steht schon länger unter Druck Schulden
in Milliardenhöhe und als vergangenes
Jahr Wirtschaftsprüfer den Abschluss
nicht beglaubigten stürzte die Aktie ab
heute nun durchsuchten Ermittler Büros
der Tochter Adler real estate in
mehreren deutschen und europäischen
Städten der Verdacht falsch Bilanzierung
mag Manipulation und Untreue Isabel de
la Vega zu den Hintergründen
mit Prestigeprojekten wie diesem
Wohnturm in Berlin wurde die Adler GROUP
zu einem der größten immobilienkonzerne
Deutschlands 175 am Mittler der
Staatsanwaltschaft Frankfurt und des BKA
untersuchen seit dem Morgen europaweit
21 Objekte darunter die Geschäftsräume
des Tochterunternehmens in Berlin der
Verdacht ehemalige Vorstände sollen sich
der Untreue Bilanzfälschung und
Marktmanipulation schuldig gemacht haben
Zitat es besteht weiterhin der Verdacht
dass die Beschuldigten Scheingeschäfte
tätigten um Preise für Projekte in die
Höhe zu treiben
in Finanzkreisen wird schon länger
spekuliert das Adler den Wert seiner
Immobilien beschönige
der Fall erinnert an Wirecard auch bei
der Adler geht es darum gewinnen zu
zeigen die eigentlich nicht da sind und
damit den Kapitalmarkt zu überzeugen
investiert in meine Aktie und geht mir
Geld mit Bankdaten
Wirtschaftsprüfer von KPMG hatten das
Unternehmen im vergangenen Jahr
durchleuchtet und die Bescheinigung für
den korrekten Jahresabschluss verweigert
seither singt die Aktie neben Aktionären
könnten auch Kunden die Wohnungen
gekauft haben betroffen sein
für Wohnungseigentümer besteht die Sorge
dass eigentlich die vertraglichen
Verpflichtung welche die Art der restate
AG eingegangen ist dass die dem nicht
nachkommen kann das heißt Wohnung werden
nicht ausgebaut Wohnung werden nicht
fertig gebaut und man muss dann mit der
Art der realstate AG in den Rechtsstreit
darüber geben neue Wohnungen werden
dringend gebraucht ein immobilienskandal
kommt dazu und Zeit
bezahlbaren Wohnraum finden in ganz
Deutschland ist das ein Riesenthema die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner stimmten vor
zwei Jahren in einem Volksentscheid für
die Enteignung bzw Vergesellschaftung
großer Wohnungsbauunternehmen dass dies
auch juristisch möglich sein zu diesem
Schluss kommt jetzt eine
Expertenkommission aber was genau
bedeutet das auch vor dem Hintergrund
eines inzwischen neu gewählten Senates
aus Berlin romaneskova mit Spannung
erwartet die Übergabe des
Abschlussberichts darf Berlin Wohnungen
großer Unternehmen vergesellschaften
lautete die zentrale Frage trotz
Meinungsverschiedenheiten in der
Kommission im Grundsatz das Votum
eindeutig Artikel 15 unseres
Grundgesetzes lässt dieses Tun auch
durch Landesgesetz aber Sie müssen
unglaublich viele
Detailfragen beantworten eingesetzt
wurde die Kommission noch von der alten
Rot-Grün roten Koalition grund war der
gewonnene Volksentscheid der Initiative
Deutsche Wohnen und Co enteignen ihre
Anforderung die Bestände von Unternehmen
mit mehr als 3000 Wohnungen in Berlin
vergesellschaften die neue CDU
SPD-Regierung hat bislang nur ein
unverbindliches Rahmengesetz vereinbart
der regierende bleibt trotz des Votums
zurückhaltend das ist kein Geheimnis
dass ich was das Thema
Vergesellschaftung angeht stets
skeptisch war
ich bin es immer noch dabei findet
Berlins enteignungsinitiative
mittlerweile Nachahmer auch in anderen
Städten etwa in Hamburg mögliche
milliardenschwere Entschädigungen die
Berlinern immobilienkonzerne zahlen
müsste schrecken sie nicht ab das
kommissionsergebnis ganz in ihrem Sinne
wir haben dafür gestimmt und
haben alle Ergebnisse der Kommission zu
arbeiten in vielen Regionen bleibt der
Wohnungsmarkt angespannt
Vergesellschaftungen als Mittel im Kampf
gegen explodierende Mieten sind
umstritten das expertenvotum heute
erstmal nur ein Finger zeigt
die Beatles die waren absolute
songwriting-koryphäen musikalisch extrem
innovativ mit riesig kulturellem
Einfluss und bahnbrechendem Erfolg klar
dass sie nachfolgenden Generationen
einen nachhaltiges Erbe hinterließen
nach wie vor werden aus diesem Nachlass
immer wieder neue Schätze gehoben und
über den jüngsten der ab heute in der
National Portrait Gallery in London zu
sehen ist berichtet jetzt Andreas Stamm
aus London
dunkle Wolken über New York ein Sturm
zieht auf die Beatles erobern die Welt
Februar 64 die erste US-Tour
Geburtsstunde der beetlemania
festgehaltenen bislang
unveröffentlichten Fotos von Paul
McCartney
als wir das erste Mal nach Amerika kamen
irgendwie Kinder die es in England schon
ziemlich geschafft hatten waren wir
großspurige Idioten so cool so in etwa
hey gib mir meine Zigarette aber es war
magisch
tausende negative aus drei Monaten
früher vor hatte aus dem Privatarchiv
herausgekramt für eine Ausstellung in
der National Portrait Gallery in London
250 ausgesuchten Fotos
der Beatles auf alle um sie herum nicht
wie sie von allen betrachtet werden das
ist so viel persönlicher und
faszinierender weil man spürt wie es
sich angefühlt hat so etwas
Außergewöhnliches selbst zu erleben
der 81-Jährige präsentiert einer
künftigen Königin stolz sein Berg schon
vorab eine Zeitreise zu viel
jungsspunden aus Liverpool die zum
ersten Mal Palmen sehen Zeugnisse einer
unbeschwerten Zeit die nicht nur die
Welt der Musik für immer verändert hat
[Applaus]
schicke Bilder so wir sind beim Sport zu
Katja und einer großen Überraschung ist
allerdings beim ATP-Turnier auf Mallorca
hat der deutsche Jannik hanfmann Nummer
48 der Welt den dann eins gesetzten
Griechen Stephanus zieht sie Pass im
Achtelfinale geschlagen handfahren
brauchte knapp zwei Stunden für den
Dreisatz Sieg
voll konzentriert beginnt Hansmann das
Spiel gegenpass aktueller fünfter der
Welt Rangliste gleich im ersten Spiel
gelingt ihm ein Aufschlag Break der
einzige deutsche im Turnier fällt von
Mallorca zeigt die richtige Mischung aus
Grundlinienspiel und netzangriffen gegen
einen Gegner der sein eigenes Spiel noch
nicht gefunden hat sieht sie passt
schafft kein Replay was den Griechen
zunehmend nervt
folgerichtig entscheidet hanfmann den
ersten Satz nach 34 Minuten mit sechs zu
vier für sich aber der 31 Jahre alte
Karlsruhe kann sein hohes Niveau nicht
ganz halten Doppelfehler
aufschlagverlust den zweiten Satz
gewinnt der Favorit mit sechs zu drei
doch zieht sie Pass hat seine Nerven
nicht im Zaum straffpunkt wegen bald weg
Schlagens hanfman nutzt die break-chance
und nach einer Stunde und 45 Minuten
auch seinen ersten Matchball zum Sex zu
zweit wieder hat Janning Hartmann der
Spätstarter eine Gegner aus den Top 10
der Weltrangliste geschlagen
bei den European Games sind Krakau Polen
waren die Deutschen wasserspringerinnen
und Springer überaus erfolgreich 6
Medaillen gewann sie für den DSV für den
goldenen Abschluss sorgte Timo Bartel
vom 10 Meter Turm mit diesem nahezu
perfekten letzten Sprung verbesserte er
sich von Rang zwei auf eins und sicherte
den deutschen Team damit auch einen
Quotenplatz für die Olympischen Spiele
in Paris im kommenden Jahr
weniger zufriedenstellend lief es für
die deutschen Hockey Männer beim Pool
liegt Turnier einer Turnierserie mit
neuen internationalen Top Teams die über
6 Monate geht Deutschland in den weißen
Trikots verlor in Amsterdam verdient mit
0 zu 2 gegen die Niederlande und liegt
in der Tabelle momentan auf Frank 5 zwei
Spiele stehen in der kommenden Woche
noch aus zweimal geht's gegen Spanien
und auch die Deutschen hockeyfrauen
haben eben gerade verloren eins zu drei
gegen Neuseeland so ist Sport danke mal
gucken wie Lotto ist ihr sind die
gewinnzahlen vom Mittwoch 5 18 28 30 34
37 und die Superzahl 1 weitere
Gewinnzahlen und Infos auf lotto.zdf.de
und auf der ZDF Text Seite 557
morgen zu erwarten neue Gewitter mit
Starkregen mehr gleich im Wetter von
Österreich
später um 21:45 Uhr startet das heute
journal mit Marietta Slomka ein Fokus
Wassermangel in Deutschland ja das war
es von uns schönen Dank fürs zuschauen
und sehr gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Kaltfront
eines Tiefs bei Island die ina hat sich
allmählich und bringt morgen im
Nachmittag erste Show und Gewitter die
können schon kräftig sein mit Starkregen
davor wird ordentlich warme Luft dies
teilweise auch feucht aus dem Süden
herangeführt und so steigen die
Temperaturen noch mal kräftig an die
Kaltfront erreicht uns dann zum Freitag
und dann können die Gewitter durchaus
auch stärker sein und im unwetterbereich
Liegen schauen wir uns die Nacht an
Nordwesten gibt es etwas Regen sonst
klartes auf und in Bayern wird es kalt
mit Werten bis 8 Grad sonst 18 Grad ganz
im Westen Deutschlands und morgen am
Vormittag im Westen erste Schauer
ansonsten bleibt es trocken zum
Nachmittag wenn aus den Schauern dann
auch allmählich Gewitter und die können
durchaus stark kriegen dabei haben im
Südosten bleibt es größtenteils sonnig
Temperaturen dazu bis 30 Grad am
Oberrhein und 23 Grad an der Nordsee die
nächsten Tage am Freitag kommt die
Kaltfront überquert uns teils Unwetter
artige Gewitter 20 bis 27 Grad und
danach ist es nicht mehr ganz so warm
ein schöner Abend